With the first one, the units of measurement would be okay for a rate of change of tons per year.
If you look at this first expression, you see that it's not doing what it supposed to be doing.
Actually we are still multiplying the current amount of fish by 0.5 per year
but still the same growth rate all of the time.
The second term 0.5 per year times minus 10⁶ tons
is just similar to harvesting a huge the amount of harvesting--this cannot be the solution.
The third option doesn't work because the unit of measurement are wrong.
Tons times tons divided by year, tons squared per year. That's not what we want to have.
The second one is the one that works.
The initial rate of change that's 0.5 per year is multiplied by a factor that's 1
if the amount of fish is 0--1 minus 0 over something and is multiplied by 0
if that amount is 10⁶ tons 1 minus 10⁶ tons/10⁶ tons.
This factor modifies the initial rate of change in the way that we need it
and here of course, we don't have harvesting.